a Wheel of Fortune contestant has gone
viral after making a wildly
inappropriate guess on the show yeah
check it out yeah the answer was kicking
back but she guessed chasing tail I mean
can you blame her Andy what are you what
are you talking about what do you mean
that show is always trying to trick you
into guessing something inappropriate
it's happened to me so many times look
at this tape okay Pat I'm gonna solve it
the [ __ ] stops here the answer is the
buck stops here I think I better solve
it Pat [ __ ] [ __ ] goose [ __ ] up the draw
[ __ ] of the Irish [ __ ] be a lady tonight
new shoes buck in the saddle again [ __ ]
in the box
[ __ ] the quarter [ __ ]
mighty [ __ ] made up [ __ ] be with you
Joy Luck Club long haul [ __ ]
puppet finger [ __ ] good [ __ ] engine
bucket with a good [ __ ]
Wayne the [ __ ] job Starbucks monster
[ __ ] rally Buckingham Palace Green Bay
[ __ ] [ __ ]
are you sure
how many times have you been on that
show a lot but I always wore my lucky
shirt how is that gonna be on TV